بعد اسبوع من توليه المنصب تعيينات
السوداني الجديده ومستمره خمسه تغييرات
داخل مكتبه الشخصي جاءت بعد تغييرات اخرى
في مناصب امنيه عليا تجنب الاطار
التنسيقيه الذي جاء به للحكومه اعلان
موقفه بشكل واضح منه
سياسي بالطبع يعيشه معظم المسؤولين الجدد
مع الشعب والسوداني ليس استثناءا عكست
قراراته الاخيره محاوله دغدغه المشاعر
الشعب تغييره بالمناصب العليا
لمكافحه الفساد لكن بما انه مدعوم من قبل
الاطار التنسيقي الموالي لايران هل هي في
رئيس الحكومه المكلف بوعوده فعلا عن هذه
التغييرات في المناصب الامنيه تنضرب
بالخلافات
ما اريد اي وزير
يصدر اوامر ويبدا التغييرات وتعديلات في
وزاره
واحنا جايين ننتقم او جاي نحذف ونلغي
الناس اللي موجوده كل الموجودين هم موظفين
في الدوله العراقيه
لكن هل سيشك طريقه بعيدا عن الاطار المولي
لايران الذي اجلسه على كرسي
ذلك التصفيه حاضره للسابقين عكس حديث
السوداني وتماما كما حرض المسؤول الامني
ليش يا حزب الله العراقي والملقب بابو علي
العسكري لنا حقوق يجب تحصيلها من الاشياء
عراقيه بدات في لعبه خطره والبدايه مع
الرجل الاول على لائحه تصفيه الحسابات
مصطفى الكاظمي
[موسيقى]
لكان هناك صله اعماق توصل السوداني
بالميليشيات وتتسع دائرتها مع الوقت
مكتبوا الاتصالات لرئيس الوزراء العراقي
الجديد التعيينات وبدات لكن بمن
معد واشنطن لسياسه الشرق الادنى الادنى
سلط الضوء على الامر ربيع نادر مديرا
للمكتب الاعلامي لرئيس الوزراء صحفيو
معروفا بالعملي طويلا مع جماعته جماعات
المصنفه على لائحه الارهاب والموظفون في
هذه القنوات الاعلانيه التي عمل بها نادر
سابقا
يصلا لتدقيق امنيا شخصيه على يد الحارس
الثوري الايراني والاختيار يتم بناء على
التقارب الايدولوجي يبدو هذا جليا في
منشورا السابق لنادر على مواقع التواصل
اعيد نشره عقب توليه منصبه يخلد ذكر جنازه
ابو مهدي المهندس الذي قتل مع قاسم سليمان
بغاره امل امريكيه في يناير من العام 2020
ولافتت هو ان ربيع نادر نفسه انضم لي قسم
الاتصالات خلال رئاسه عادل عبد المهدي لكن
متى جاء تهميشه عندما تولى الكاظم
المسؤوليه رغم اتصالات السوداني المستمره
مع واشنطن منذ متولي المنصب اخرها بوزير
الخارج
بالاصلاحات التي وعد بها العراقيين لكن
يبدو ان مكتب السوداني مهدده بالعقبات ان
استمرت هذه التعيينات بحسب تقرير معهد
واشنطن السؤال اين المعارضه من كل هذه
القرارات والتعيينات ونتحدث عن الصدر
الغائب عن المشهد منذ تولي السوداني
والظاهره اخيرا وبلا سياسه